I'm gonna be so crap
at this game
'cause I don't watch TV.
All you need to know is whether
it's one from our show or not.
Still won't have a clue.
(LAUGHS)
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
EVE BEST: I'm gonna go first.
"I'm going to grind
his fucking bones
to make my bread."
That actually isn't
from our show.
-I'm gonna say that's from
Succession, actually.
-(BELL DINGS)
-Is it? Yes, I thought so.
-That's the right answer.
'Cause I-- Do you know what?
I hear Brian Cox.
I'm going to grind
his fucking bones
to make my bread.
Okay, bye.
"If you can quote the rules,
you can fucking obey them."
I don't think it's
from our show.
Want to hazard a guess
as to what it might be from,
if it isn't from our show?
No, I've got absolutely
nought idea.
Well, you're right,
it's not from our show.
It's actually Tony Soprano
from The Sopranos.
(MIMICS TONY)
"If you can quote the rules,
you can fucking obey them."
If you can quote the rules,
you can fucking obey them.
You hear me?
-EVE BEST: Okay, my turn.
-I'm hoping it says something--
I can't-- I can't undo it.
Will you open it for me?
I'm not gonna try and undo it.
-Okay, there.
-Okay.
"You go to war with the army
you have, right?"
That's not from our show either.
But I don't know
what it is from.
"You go to war with the army
you have, right?"
"You go to war with the army--"
I'm not doing
the person, I'm just...
No, no, that's-- I thought--
I was saying it wasn't
from our show,
but now I'm just
thinking of a scene.
"You go to war with the army
you have, right?"
Okay, I'm gonna say
it is from our show.
-(ALARM BLARES)
-Wrong answer.
It's Sidney Purcell, Veep.
Veep? Oh, my God, I was looking
at Veep the other day.
Boy, I just wish I ordered
a plate of useless assholes.
But you go to war with
the army you have, right?
Here we go.
"It's meant to be shared, grief.
It's insurmountable.
Too difficult a battle
to be waged alone."
I'm going to hazard a guess
that it may be from our show.
I think it might be
one of the things
that one of the girls say
to each other.
-Alicent and--
-The way Alicent and Rhaenyra
might say to each other.
-Okay. So...
-(ALARM BLARES)
Are those the wrong answer?
Totally wrong, wrong show?
It's actually from
Big Little Lies.
-Huh.
-Yeah. (CHUCKLES)
It's meant to be shared, grief.
It's insurmountable.
Too difficult a battle
to be waged alone.
Last one. (LAUGHS)
That could mean so many
different things, that laughter.
"One must not await the storm."
(LAUGHS)
I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and say that
that is from our show.
I'm also gonna go out on a limb
and say that line is said
by one Lord Corlys Velaryon,
the Sea Snake.
To elude a storm,
you can either sail into it...
or around it.
But you must never await
its coming.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪